Where are you right now,
and can I come and, like, craft with you?
Please do.
I am in my happy place, my craft room.
Which, yes, it's my sanctuary.
Oh my gosh.
I was watching your new movie this weekend,
and you're blossoming into such a woman.
And as the fact that we were both kind of like,
well, we both weren't kind of,
we were kids who grew up in this business.
Oh, yeah.
And do you see yourself as an adult yet?
Do you still feel like you're playing house?
what is our deal?
I know.
Well, I think that I've always been a child at heart
and now I feel like
I'm kind of the happiest because I get to be a kid,
but I'm the adult, so, like, I can have a craft room
and you know, I can be responsible
and still be my kid-self.
I remember like, people thinking that I was a kid
for a really long time and I didn't get that.
I was like, no, I feel like an adult.
You and I--
No I can understand.
In your situation, because you were so famous
at such a young age and, you know,
working with child actors.
I didn't work as much as you did as a kid,
but there is this, like need to be a lot older
and more sophisticated than you would be,
you know, at school on a playground.
So I could see why you're like,
"Well wait, no, I've just been doing this.
"I'm an adult at, you know, eight."
Yes.
Like I
totally get that.
Well, we were both in commercials as kids.
I got teased so much about that commercial
that it sort of traumatized me a little bit.
And I had an audition for like, feminine hygiene product
right after that while it was airing,
and I was already so mortified
about just talking about my dad's indigestion
(laughs)
that when I went to the audition
and I read the sides and it was all about,
"Oh, my heavy flow and what do I do?"
And I was like, "I can't do this.
"I can't even talk about my dad's ingestion."
I love this story so much.
I can't even tell you,
I've talked about how I like my mom
would get me filet of fish every audition I didn't get,
which was like 'cause then she was like,
"Also like watch your weight
"but here's a filet of fish."
It was really confusing.
Mixed signal.
Yeah, it's exactly.
I was in this commercial as a kid.
I know what kids do to you when you do dip
into school and it's merciless.
Like, and you don't feel like you can complain
about it 'cause we have these amazing lives
and we don't wanna be like, "Oh, school was hard on us."
I swear, these kids are relentless.
Well, then I would go to school the next day
and they'd be like, "Do you think you're special
'cause you got to skip school yesterday
"and act with Snap, Crackle and Pop?"
(laughing)
Yeah, oh, I feel ya.
You know what?
We made it, we're adults.
Hey.
We're moms.
We're getting to play moms.
You have been happily married for seventeen years?
I know, I know.
And he was really slow to propose.
So we've actually been together
like 20-plus years.
Really?
I was like, "See if you proposed earlier,
"we could have like been celebrating
"our 20th wedding anniversary."
I still hold him to that.
'Cause I sort of knew right away.
I was like, "Yeah, let's go."
And he was super slow.
How was like your quarantine year
even though it's still going on?
Yes, I mean you know, it's the roller coaster
but I certainly, it could be a lot worse.
We really like being together as a family,
which is a plus.
And you know, I just, I'm really good
at like sort of making the best out of a situation.
So when it first started, I was like,
"Girls, we get to walk to school now."
So we leave the front door and then go to the side door
and we'd sing this, like, you know
song about not getting coronavirus
and, you know like stuff like that.
So obviously, there've been difficult,
you know days and as well, but overall,
I try to sort of realize that this is time
that when they're in college, I'm going to be like,
"Oh remember when they couldn't leave the house?
"It was so nice."
I know, it's so true.
I don't want them to ever leave.
I keep having fantasies, like Olive could go
to college down the street, but like still live at home.
Yeah, the key to that great snacks.
You have to have like, things that they're excited about.
Yeah, so that's why I get all like crazy
with my crafting food and stuff.
(upbeat music)